we will now invite mr thai lee seung
executive director of usg under the
building and construction authority to
share his thoughts on what a good design
research project should encapsulate
thank you lisa
thanks judea very good afternoon to
every one of you
um in today's
highly competitive business world
products and services have to
meet often complex requirements
it's no longer just about trade
it's also about social it's about
environment
so with such a complexities
the only way to succeed in in design is
really to
incorporate research into the process
and in the first batch of applications
we do come across some applications
that i in my view wrongly associate
research as
just simply the creative process
so i think even in my view of
architecture we have heard
some of our practitioners who look at
who say that okay as we design we
we are actually doing research but
that's not quite the case
to me research is a scientific process
that requires the right identification
of problem statement oftentimes i think
this is
where things go wrong because if you
don't identify the right
problem statement you actually go down a
pathway that
leads you to nowhere so do take time to
kind of define what is the problem and
there are applications we find that
kind of scale the problem at a too
shallower level
or sometimes it gets too ambitious and
they can't deliver the
solutions so it really had to
meet a kind of a sweet spot
and the next thing will be the right
methodology the process of
research so this is again not something
that designers are used
to some may have methodology for design
but research is again something that we
need to
even draw inspiration from the
scientific world
of course we are not doing science
scientific inventions
so there will be a difference and that's
something which we need to take some
lessons of
and i would say another important thing
in the gdr process
is finding the right partners they are
not necessarily
associated with design hue in the
traditional sense
so this is where designers must be ready
to work with
a whole range of players
which may be very upstream or maybe very
downstream
in the usual process of creating
solutions
and it could be people like data
scientists
something which again designers may not
be very used to
working with data and especially
sometimes we have to do numbers
crunching
for example another type of specialist
will be material specialist
a lot of design ideas often fall flat at
the final
implementation because at the concept
level
it sounds right it looks workable but
when you kind of
bring the action materials in you find
that you can't work with traditional
materials and you have to
almost sometimes synthesize new
materials
that's where the challenge begins and i
will also say that
we it'd be good to achieve with
downstream players like manufacturers
who have a lot of experience in making
things
the designers usually are very good at
conceptualizing but may not really
be familiar with all the boats and nuts
and that's where we bring partners in
so if i would just like to conclude is
that good design research is an
excellent program we are sitting
seeing new uh new foods yielded
especially in a second batch
it really takes design up a notch to a
different level
and and reach the outcome and creating
unique products
and services solutions in the process
that i think also very importantly is
they
actually solve our challenges in society
be social economic or environment and
bring a lot of
meaningful benefits to the end users
so i look forward to really another
batch of excellent
submissions thank you
thank you lisa for even allowing
allowing us to think about both i guess
upstream and downstream support in a
good design research project
um with that let's invite our next
evaluation panel member
mr delisha kula syria executive director
of deloitte center of
fodder age in asia to also expand on
what good design research looks like to
him
thank you delisha i think
lisiang actually covered a lot of ground
in terms of expectations
so to add to that i think the the
the video you saw showed three of
our best kind of
applicants who went through the gdr
process right they had a
clear product idea they had a clear
sense of what they were researching for
and a clear output that had impact and
value
so we're going to look for all of those
things but a few things to
to add to that
i want to step back and say why is the
gdr uh
program here in the first place it is to
elevate the overall
design ethos and design capability in in
singapore
so we are looking for a portfolio so we
do want a wide range
and in that range should be some that
are very strong in some aspects some
that are more
futuristic so we're looking for that
range right so don't feel
afraid if you feel it's too timid or if
it's too too ambitious
put forward your your proposal we'll go
through a couple of cycles
and we'll get to a good place about that
but having said that
do the do the research we there are many
applicants who came in
with what they thought was a seemingly
great idea
but without having done the research to
say that hey has this been done
elsewhere
are there other examples so when you
come to the table
please do the research to show that you
know you recognize what's already in the
marketplace or what's already been
researched
and the unique thing that you are doing
to
expand uh the knowledge base on in
in that research field right so do that
do that work
um but having said that please like
stretch
you know bring something magical bring
something new
um yes we want the high quality but we
also want you to stretch and say not
just go for what you know to do but to
stretch further away
we recognize that most of you are busy
running your business
and don't have the time or the energy or
the funds to do this piece of research
so
this is a really incredible opportunity
to get funding for that but use it
strategically
now pick the one or two things that you
always wanted to do that you couldn't
that you can research uh absolutely
underline what liaison said in bringing
the partners
use this as an opportunity to bring
together others
that you'd have had a hard time
collaborating before if you're a
designer bring a manufacturer into it
if you're a manufacturer bring a
marketing person into it like
find the angle of research that's been
holding you back
and see if you can craft a proposal on
that
but make sure that the proposal you
craft is also adding something new
not just to you but to the overall
topic or the industry that you're in i
think that's what would make it
make it very successful in my side my
evaluation so thank you
thank you delisha i think that was a
very encouraging for our designers to be
more experimental
with their design research practice it's
the magic that they can add right
um finally let's welcome miss cristina
ventura
who is the founder and ceo of venturax
ventures
to close this segment with her thoughts
on what good design research should
encapsulate
christina please thank you judea for the
great session
so it's an honor again to be here
because last year guys we were working
together
with alicia and this young and we are
all very aligned
so i'm going to support definitely all
his points
there were four areas that we were
looking and
dcr would love as well that we worked
together guys on this
so one is like what a good proposal
would entail in a very
simple value proposition so how in a
sentence would you enhance the customer
experience and to truly
do good and do well you know so what
does that would mean
and what does that product or experience
would impact people's lives so how to
enhance customer experience i believe
that's
number one then the other one is as well
the
fully agreed with the comments already
made the research so we loved last year
the one that
you guys they made an incredible
in-depth research
so as you might know 60 of the projects
normally fail or
do not get funded because there weren't
there was no need for that
so in this case if you have a deep
research that then proves your
project service that would be great
because that supports definitely the
fact that
that might be needed and definitely
after cover there's plenty of
opportunities
so that would be the second point what
is expected in depth of the research
then the third the impact so there's
different ways of measuring impact
i love to measure in three areas more in
the people planet
and profit so in these three areas so if
i
you can share in um in depth analysis
how that
impact um you know the community the
long term
of course singapore as well but maybe
southeast asia or maybe globally
how this could be scalable and
sustainable per se because something if
it does do good and well is good if it's
sustainable so these three areas of
impact
and then as well very important the
follow-on follow-through so how this
could be
implemented immediately maybe you are
already working on that
maybe you are shaping a bit so it can be
applicable for the project and therefore
we can definitely help you
i'm helping and follow up a couple of
them already and as well
considering um investing in one of them
because they're doing extremely well i
love what they do
so that as well one of the ideas how can
we support guys
from not only the day itself but as well
afterwards through mentorship through
investment through network connections
expansion and so on and then
one of the areas for example of as well
measurement
could be the relevance of the idea i
have
done a few areas that i believe was very
important relevance the disability
of the product or service as well the
innovation how innovative is the idea
is it something new or is something you
know that is building from
something that already existed how
innovative and disruptive it is
how feasible extremely important as well
so could be innovative but if it's not
feasible to execute might not be so
relevant so feasibility is important
sustainability uh all of us were huge
believers in sustainability as you know
so not only sustainability at the
project or service but as well
sustainability of the business model
so we love to see the idea on how
sustainable it is to execute
and last but not least the impact yeah
so relevance disability
innovation feasibility sustainability
and
the impact over the overall project so
anything you need these days as well
before you present feel free to reach
to us and it's important that the idea
is again very clear
strong proposal with a deep research
assessment the impact of the project and
the follow-up follow-through that you
might need and that we can support you
with
thank you christina for that very
generous sharing
and the rest of the panel members as
well so as we move on
into the next segment which is q a can i
request for the evaluation panels to
leave their cameras
on at this point while i invite our
moderator
and supported gdr designers on stage so
let's welcome joe so
a moderator for a q a session and also
the deputy director of our industry
development office in dsg
along with our supported designers from
past gdr open calls
morgan who's the director of roger and
sons
and tamiya together with jean lee who
are founders and co-founders of
gb studio so thank you everyone for
being here today
and joe over to you let me just kick
things off
uh and so to help everybody all
interested applicants with the
submissions
for gdr i just want to go straight to
an evaluation panelists first i think
falling on to the very interesting
points that everyone has raised i wanted
to ask and i'll just
carry pick somebody right now uh lisang
what do you think a strong proposal
entails
well um i think christina has
a touch on that point uh to me i think i
would just use the word clarity
sometimes we find that when the proposal
comes to us
and even with in-person presentation
there is a lack of clarity so clarity
really is
going back to fundamental what is the
problem what is the challenge
so if that is not even articulated clear
enough
i can 100 guarantee you the solutioning
will be
worse it's not going to be anywhere
clearer let's say the challenge
statement
or problem statement need not um
be something too complex
so sometimes i find the simplicity is
blessed so
and and they are very obvious and very
apparent in today's world we're full of
problems
so just pick something that you can
manage
and you think there is a horizon for
innovation
uh i think that will take you a long way
and i i use uh
one example here i think morgan is here
about local trees that stays in my mind
very strongly
because it is a problem we have tons of
trees and what do you do with them
so with that simple problem statement
they created
interesting solutions that we could have
done this many many years ago but
again the timing is right for them so
that's my take
thank you lisang i mean i did pick up
that all three evaluation panelists
said clarity is super important um i
think they
people might also be kind of fraught
with how clear is too clear
i mean because there was something about
identifying the right challenge
statement problem statement to address
don't go too shallow don't be too
ambitious
so they're trying to find in order to
find the right um
uh space between these sort of
parameters being innovative and yet
being clear at the same time
and yet researching is something they
don't know anything about
so um i don't know judiciary examples
that come to mind which is a good idea
of
clear but still ambitious
well the ambitious part
is what should capture our imagination
right and to what lease young said what
morgan did
with like 2300 trees get caught in
singapore
and we don't do much with it like that
like just like a big there's something
big going on that gets you like wow
there's some like all the num
like um in terms of the
number of water bottles that get thrown
out or the recycling
like there has to be a bigger piece that
if we were to solve this bigger
but then once you have that bigger piece
you really have to narrow it down to
something that is manageable
within the time and scale and so forth
right that's again
important so that's why you have to say
the problem statement like there's a big
problem certain and there's a minor
problem statement that you're going to
go do with the gdr
with this research and so make the big
one be as imaginative creator make the
small one be kind of
tangible so that you can clearly
understand what
you will achieve at the end of the time
i think that's what you're looking for
right
it's the mix between there's a big
ambitious magical thing but there's also
like
a piece that that this will lead to a
tangible result
in the direction of that big piece okay
yes
also because the highlight to everybody
the program has there is a limit
time limit and then that is just 12
months in the end of 12 months you have
to show a proof of concept
so but that's also one of the criteria
in which we measure or assess
a um a proposal as well and just a side
note uh
yes i discovered uh
morgan and uh um the work
through raj and sons through the good
design research project
and we have one of the tables in our
office it's a beautiful piece
that we talk to everyone about great
thank you delisha
well morgan you've been brought up twice
now i have to bring you on and
ask you about your research how was it
for you what were there some challenges
that you faced in your
research work yeah uh
i i think for for us uh you know the
bigger picture
is it's just the amount of trees that
has been cut down in singapore so
singapore cuts uh
unofficially about 100 trees a day we
don't really see about it or know about
them
and so the idea was to start the
locatory project to
to really solve this problem and we
didn't know how to go about to do it
and we really wanted to find users for
the trees
so we went into the goody design
research with this big picture of how we
want to be able to
use different parts of the trees
eventually you know with the branches
and the leaves and the roots and all
sorts of things
but then we narrow it down and we say
you know the first thing and the most
important thing is
finding out more about these trees that
means what the properties of the local
wood you know are
we able to stabilize it you know how do
we work with it properly
and i think as a small firm uh i mean we
have a lot of
friends and people asking me hey morgan
why do we try doing this or try doing
that but i think as small businesses
owners we
reverse short of resources especially
with money time
and as well as a manpower you know i
think and i think with this
research that has been uh that we have
undertaken it kind of gave us the
opportunity to go out
and engage a professional that will be
able to give us really good feedback you
know and really gives us a proper
scientific
measurements and and properties about
the local wood
and then with that also to do a bit of
research on how to densify it so it's
kind of win-win because uh
now we have finally uh information about
how the local wood
are and then how we can can densify it
and i think it's for us
it was really difficult because we
always want to do research right and
i think for us we don't know how to do
it you know who do we go and engage
do we go and speak to research companies
or who and when being a very small firm
we're just very afraid that nobody uh
just would like to entertain us
so i was very happy that when when we
spoke to
to dsg about you know other partners
that they can recommend to us
uh for us to be able to to meet like
research companies
uh so dsg kind of introduced us to ipi
so ipi is actually a arm for enterprise
singapore where they
they gather companies and and they have
research companies as well as
people looking for research so they
introduced us to them and i was speaking
to elvin from ipi it was very very
helpful
introducing us to different partners and
yeah so it's really quite a great
experience for us
can i ask quickly how did you even think
about using the trees off of the side of
our highways i mean did you just look up
at trees one day and say
i wonder how many trees get cut down
actually this all started with uh monday
so monday uh development came to us and
asked us whether or not uh because
we're going to cut some trees for the
new development uh for the new park
so there was this the guy who was in
charge in monday for sustainability
so he came to us and said hey you know
we're gonna cut some trees do you wanna
make
and turn them into furniture and then i
told him that you know it's our first
time trying have you never tried it
before but if you're willing to
go on this journey you know we're
willing to try it out for for we've
reviewed
so we did on that job and as we were
going in and we're talking to the uncles
and we're seeing the amount of trees
that has been cut down we just realized
that it's a big big problem that we have
now
it just doesn't make sense to import
work for overseas when you have
perfectly googled that you can try to
to work in singapore just that the issue
the issue in singapore is that we don't
have the time like all these uncles and
older guys they don't really
have the time money resources or the
determination to be able to spend
resources to go and research onto it
and so so with this it really kind of
gives us an opportunity to
to share the information not only to
ourselves because this information is
is given to the public and we want to be
able to share with other carpenters with
other people so that there will be more
uses for for these trees now
okay great because you are from the
first batch of um
a cohort the br designers that came on
and that point in time we didn't hadn't
officially had um
challenge statements from corporates yet
but you in fact
in effect got a problem statement from
the um people right who told you about
this because i
i guess our the way we uh get rid of our
treasure is so well we don't even see
the trees
being disposed somewhere so we wouldn't
have trouble coming our solution for
that
okay thanks very much morgan i'm just
gonna ask uh jin lee a question now well
tamir and jin from jindi um
in in your project it's around fashion
how did you come about thinking of your
problem statement
and what you're addressing and how did
you address it
so um
in our business uh we're doing fashion
business there's a lot of waste
that because of the way that
things are made because of the way the
industry
operates um this industry
basically creates a lot of waste a lot
of uh sown
goods that no one is buying it creates a
vicious circle
in um that you know you see it and the
discounts you know the season people
trying to get rid of
stuff and we thought that something is
wrong with the whole thing
um and we kind of it's a certain point
we decided okay this is our mission
we're gonna fight this waste
we're gonna make our operation more um
effective and more efficient
and we had a vision that
we wanted to create we wanted to make
things in the shop
because we figured out that
if you make it if you have the ability
to make it in the shop
means that you can actually fulfill
what the customer wants right
so if uh if it's made in the shop
upon request there is no waste right so
this vision was there at the beginning
and in good design research
we had to figure out how to how to
achieve it how to make it
and um and how has the good design
research itself
helped you move your research further
along because i'm aware that you had a i
mean
because we were both on another um
program before
i'm aware that you had a knocked up
wooden version that you made yourself
how did it
progress into the you know the gleaming
stainless steel in your store today
yeah so definitely it gives you a boost
it gives you the
ability to prototype and to actually
make things uh
more properly uh obviously um
yeah yeah you you can
yeah it made us connect to other
people other bodies that help us to
develop
and to think of ideas
yeah we had mentors that guide us
and help us to find the right direction
was there anything specific that a
mentor helped you with
um yes i think that um
you have a lot of ideas you know you
have a lot of things that
uh you kind of think that's
to work or you think that is amazing and
sometimes like another like someone
that's coming from uh
like some professional that can actually
direct you better to what
what's right what is the the right way
to do it like
maybe help you to narrow down and to
focus
like we had the overall vision of what
we want to do we want to make it in
short therefore we wouldn't do
until we will not make it until the
customer won it but then we came out
we came to obstacle that is technical
like uh
as you mentioned machinery we had
obstacle which is the processors but we
were doing pleating in the end of the
day as the last small perfume and we
find like
okay the amount of time it takes to
complete it's too long
it's not making sense like it's too long
making the plate more and it
it it get uh it get mango up too quickly
okay it doesn't make sense so there were
many many things that we were looking at
trying to solve
you know like in order to in order to
get to that vision so i think when uh
chiwei came in we spoke to him about
like all these things that we're trying
to do and realize the customer was
actually
really getting the experience part like
they were really impressed and
what's going on all that and we didn't
know how to you didn't have do you know
how to kind of like process it which one
do i do first i want to do everything
because our overall vision is there but
at the same time we find like that's
technical
and all that so it's very good in a way
that because we kind of like sat down
with him and just run through the whole
thing and he kind of like highlight to
us guys okay
this is really the magic that you're
trying to bring across why are you
touching on this you know like
that could be if a paper is what you're
looking at and the
ri is so high for this course then why
try to innovate that part where it
doesn't really make sense you know okay
look at the direction that we've been
given that help to
help us to clarify a little bit of
thinking along the way
so you're really testing out different
ideas you were diverging and then the
mentor came and helped me to converge
and come to a resting point at the end
of the 12 months right
yeah thanks jyn can i also ask can i
have a quick account
just to be fair i have acquired many
pieces from
uh jane and tamira as well they make
beautiful stuff
so i have a piece myself too me too
super nice thank you and they appreciate
getting other opinions from mentors that
are not husband or wife
christina yes lisa yeah christina go
ahead go ahead
you haven't made any comments yeah i
wanted to give christina a chance
because we have about say like 10
minutes left
christina how is your experience so far
with uh mentoring because i understand
you're mentoring
uh one or two brands right now correct
so
very interesting question guys because i
had the two extremes type of experience
so ones that you know we met a couple of
times and they were extremely attentive
they
understood you know the importance of
going as well
scalable and sustainable to have a
strong business model
but then i didn't hear anything back you
know so it was more like
they saw that they were you know lacking
a bit of um
shaping on the business model to be able
to scale but then there was no falling
out from their side
so i couldn't of course doing anything
else you know but then the other extreme
i had someone that said christina i need
your help can you please
do more sessions with me which of course
i said yes and we had already
several sessions we met constantly to
the point that i'm
happy to invest as well has been
extremely dedicated extremely
responsible
and really you know willing as well to
take some of the comments and some of
the feedback
and we are working together to make that
happen so great
there's no right or wrong i mean i
understand if somebody prefers to keep a
small business
not to grow just go local and
you know being able to survive you know
so it's fine
or if they want to go more you know
global
they were future at both for example i
connected them as well with different
areas and now they're ready to thrive
and to go more global
so again no it's totally personal but
i'm happy to
you know like holding the goal i'm sure
to go as far as needed
that's good sharing thank you that's
good sharing because i think that
essentially tells um interested
applicants that this is how you maximize
the mentorship that you're paired with
not just have one meeting and go off
but be be really put your skin in the
game and be really committed
thank you christina lisiang might you
like to just um
share what you wanted to share i just
wanted to use
tamiya and jean's example to again
reinforce the point that
they saw a problem a very needful
problem
that seriously i don't think
there's enough effort globally to solve
so a very simple identification of
problem
the second thing is the solution they
have some idea
about making in short so
again this is something we thought as
the evaluation panel
has tremendous potential because it has
a kind of a
legacy in that people used to tailor me
in shock right
but today you can't do it but why you
know
and that's exactly why people like to
buy fashion as unique to themselves
so that's how the panel saw the
potential of this
and picked the pick the project for gdr
i hope this actually will inspire those
who are listening in
to see that we're not looking for an
always very unique or very complex
problem
we're looking at a problem that is very
prevalent not just locally but even
globally
and then we're looking for a potentially
impactful solution
and the rest is actually i wanted to say
that the
process is not going to be just they
themselves solving it
we together as a team together as panel
as mentor
will help to enrich the solution as far
as we can
thank you very much thanks young talisha
may i also
ask you to speak on some of the softer
projects that you've mentored on so
so far we've been talking about wooden
furniture and pieces
and fashion some of the softer ones are
harder there's one right now
around music and frankly
they're struggling they had an idea
which they came in with a partner that
they had anchored but the partner kind
of fell out
so now they're they're trying to retool
themselves and and
and we will have some of those right
like and and it's okay so
part of it is kind of again going back
to the recognition that this
effort from design singapore council is
to elevate the whole design
um kind of the using design
and good design in in the process so
um those are to be expected okay it was
part and parcel of the experimentation
that shouldn't be the expectation from
us
or from them but it is also to be
expected that one or two
things might struggle um i don't think
any of the
other softer ones well the other ones
are the one that
uh tangy did again was not a tangible
kind of like
physical output but very strong but then
again he had many many years of research
backing him up
again tackling very very big problems
very structured
and that was the easy yes and they will
deliver on that and they are
therefore expanding on that i'm looking
forward to their output that we can then
take
and take to other places as well because
they really are pushing the boundary and
doing community-based research
so for example if i take the first
example you gave um the music project
the performances project right so how
are you helping to
without divulging too much how are you
having to shape and mentor
these incubators or mentees well we are
at a bit of a stall space right now
because we
explore who else they might partner with
we explore what else they might look at
but
ultimately comes back to them to go back
do the work do the research and come
back with a kind of
a proposal to get back on track
basically it comes back down to i mean
essentially if i may summarize um
correct me if i'm wrong the
the process to research and innovation
is not a linear one it's not straight
you can go in funny little circles and
backwards and forwards um
but you can guide them and give them
connections and
and mentor them but ultimately it's the
participants who have to do the work and
roll up the sleeves right
like gin and tomato said they had
multiple things they want to do and they
got some direction it seemed like the
right thing they went after it
it turned out to be a great a great way
to focus what they were doing
there's another project around kanaf
that lis young is helping with
and he heard them and said like guys
this is too small
i'm going to bring you into bca and
we're going to figure how to scale this
so they might have a scaled ambition
from what they started
off as a result of that right so again
these things can
get narrowed down and focus based on the
impact
on the the input or they could get
scaled up based on the input
could get many different directions but
as far as the proposal goes
put your best foot forward for something
ambitious
yet something that is achievable in
within the research context
and after that you know be open to where
it might take you
that's a good thing that you touched on
which is about outcomes
what do you expect um the follow-through
of the projects
should ideally be do they just research
and end it there
on one extreme example or do they
conquer the world what do you think
they they should they should at a
minimum follow through on the pledge
right they are getting a grant
with on the on the basis of uh what on
the proposal so they should follow 200
proposals and follow up on that
now if you um of any
grouping i'd say like 20 30 will run
into snacks from that what they proposed
and those are the ones that had to
re-tool and say are we like which
direction are they going
um some other ones would come in and do
exactly what they said some would come
in and do that and more and some will
kind of struggle to get where they
wanted to
and maybe get redirected to a different
option but i think it's it's
um what winning the grant is only one
part of it
um seeing it through and helping the
overall
design community is the bigger one
and all the folks we have here on on
tomorrow gin and morgan are those who
are elevating kind of the design scene
and we want to bring more and more into
the fold here
and what we're hoping from the next
cycle and onwards is to build more of a
community
around them so they can start helping
each other and expanding
uh this whole program thank you thank
you delisha for sharing those points
christina you've raised your hand my
virtual hand
just to support as well malicious point
because that was very relevant last year
in fact joe
remember that the ones that win i mean
it's a responsibility as well it's such
an
honor to be part of this process and uh
it's a lot of money
you know that they earned as well and
it's a beautiful opportunity to really
put their name and their
brand they give lisa perfect example
into the map
because singapore is becoming as you
know really the hub
for you know southeast asia innovation
design
consumer tech it's really the place to
be now
i mean what's going on in the world i
believe this is an incredible
opportunity for the participants
to take this as a catalyst for
impact and to really use all the
community because we are really working
very hard as well to make sure that
there's
um this ecosystem that we create
together
from uh fashion art design technology
all together we work to make sure that
this is just the beginning of a
long-term journey to work together to
make them
local if they want but if they want to
expand as well for sure we help them to
expand at a regional or global level
absolutely so basically you get
out of it what you put into it right
and with that i thank you all evaluation
panelists and the designers for that
time
and i'm gonna hand the virtual mic back
to julia
thank you joe that was a really
thought-provoking
q and a session thank you all for your
time and your inputs
with the questions so we hope that you
have found the session inspiring and
meaningful thus far
and as you move towards coming to a
close we are actually really curious to
hear
from you our audience to get a sense of
the interest in the room
so how many of you are interested to
participate
in our gdr open call this round could
you please respond to the poll
that should come up on your screen
anytime now
and i'll just give everyone a quick 10
seconds or so
to respond to this quickly thank you
guys
what would have been it if you had a
maybe in there in between the yes and
then
actually that's a good point
no we want 100 yes just kidding
but wow um i think
we are sharing our results now if i'm
not wrong i mean you should be able to
see on your screen
and it's really heartening to know that
of you are interested in submitting for
our good design research open call
so um thank you for your interest
and we really look forward to your
submissions and i think with what the
um evaluation panel and our designers
have said
um i think design research is still a
relatively new discipline in singapore
and we hope that this interest will
continue to grow
and inspire the larger design community
to adopt strong design research in their
practice
so on this note if you have any further
clarifications or would like to even
check
if your proposal is suitable for the gdr
initiative please feel free to reach out
to us
at industry design singapore.org
or you can also scan the qr code which
should come up on the screen really soon
for more details on the gdr initiatives
so thank you so much for all of your
time today
um both our panelists our designers and
the participants tuning in
and with this let's finally bring this
session to a close
so thank you for joining us this evening
and we hope to meet you
one day through our future events or
even as part of our gdr committee
have a delightful rest of the evening
and see you again bye